was ist ein billiger kompass man nimmt
eine banane und legt sie auf die mauer
da war abgebissen wurde das ist sowas
konnte ich mir während der
berufsschulzeit wirklich jeden tag an
von den mitschülern und von dem lehrer
mein name ist elisabeth habe ich bin 23
jahre alt aus lutherstadt wittenberg
ich war noch nicht geboren als
deutschland wiedervereinigt wurde und
ich fühle mich aus deutsch weil ich
ostdeutsch gemacht werde
ich war zwei jahre lang in bayern und
habe gemerkt was es bedeutet als
ostdeutsche junge frau in ein
westdeutsches bundesland zu ziehen wenn
ich gesagt habe wo ich herkomme
dann hatte er gegenüber meistens mitleid
mit mir weil ich ja aus dem kriegsgebiet
komme und weil alles bei uns so arm ist
und wir keine arbeit haben und kriminell
sind also das sind so die vorurteile und
es ist für mich merkwürdig dass jemand
mit mir mitleid hat weil ich aus
wittenberg kommen
[Musik]
wenn man ostdeutsch ist dann erfährt man
vorurteile eigentlich immer etwas unter
dem radar
also es ist so dass vorurteile und der
e-type dadurch sich ausdrücken wie
ostdeutschen beschrieben werden und ich
dann häufig denke huch das bin ja gar
nicht ich mein name ist janet gusko ich
bin 36 jahre alt ich bin in berlin
lichtenberg geboren und groß geworden
und als deutschland wiedervereinigt
wurde war ich sechs jahre alt
ein typisches vorurteil ist der jammer
ossi oder die jammer ossi in meinem fall
jetzt so eine zuschreibung mit der ich
mich überhaupt nicht identifizieren kann
oder so platte vorurteile wie der ganze
osten ist doch eigentlich rechts der hat
doch eigentlich gar nicht viel
beizutragen wo ist die leistung die aus
dem osten kommt ein konkretes beispiel
war als ich in frankfurt main gearbeitet
habe bei einer großen überregionalen
tageszeitungen und einfach die
verwunderung da war dass ich als aus
deutsche hier bin
es war ein gewisses exotisches interesse
an mir dass ich jetzt da sei
es ist dass man den osten nicht kennt
wie es ist im osten aufzusetzen
diese erfahrungen prägen und wenn ich
nicht die gleichen erfahrungen mit
leuten habe aus westdeutschland
dann werden wir uns nicht auf einen
nenner was es deutschsein orientieren
als identität rostock sein bedeutet für
mich nichts ist gegeben
sicherheit habe ich in dem sinne nie
kennengelernt mein name ist das print
home ist in 35 jahre alt komme gebürtig
aus magdeburg und zur wende war ich fünf
jahre alt
die ddr selbst hat eigentlich keinerlei
bedeutung für mein leben aber die
wirkung die die er hatte auch das leben
der menschen
die habe ich ja persönlich erfahren das
heißt diese diese nachwirkungen der ddr
muss ist die nämlich war
und das hat dann für mich eine gewisse
bedeutung erhält das hat mich ja
praktisch fanny mitglied in einer
kinder- oder massenorganisationen dazu
war ich einfach zu jung aber es gibt
dann halt fotos wie wir mit dem trabant
in den urlaub fahren
meine erinnerung waren eher die spuren
der ddr also dass diese leer stehendem
fabriken die auch wirklich noch bis
anfang der 2000er nahezu unverändert
darum stand thermische ändern der waren
großes russ fabrik sketch
schwermaschinen kombinates themen und
quasi so auf halber höhe keller waren
die fenster offen und auf den
schreibtischen stand schreibmaschine
vergibt das papier das hat man gesehen
das war wirklich da sind vor zehn jahren
die menschen auf gestanden haben den
raum verlassen sind den wieder gegangen
nicht mal das fenster zu kümmern
[Musik]
die erwartung meiner eltern am abend des
mauerfalls war eigentlich jetzt zählt
leistung endlich wieder und wir können
uns einbringen in diesem neuen land
meine mutter war textil ingenieuren in
der ddr und hat bereits 1990 ihren job
verloren hat dann lange probiert mit
kindern zu arbeiten und sie konnte
diesen wiedereinstieg nach dem fall der
mauer nicht schaffen weil ein aufstieg
durch weiterbildung nicht möglich war
und dieses gefühl der abwertung des 1
was wir nicht individuell als familien
schicksal teilen sondern was ich durch
den gesamten freundeskreis durch ja auch
fast jede aus deutsche familie zog das
hat mich ganz stark geprägt und mich
glaube ich auch zu dem menschen gemacht
der ich heute bin
[Musik]
arbeitslosigkeit weil mein thema bei uns
aber gefühlt für mich normal dass das
wahrheit so und ich bin noch mit denen
damit aufgewachsen dass arbeitslosigkeit
übergab ein roter bauzeichnerin zu
ostzeiten ist aber nie wieder in diesem
beruf zurück gegangen und hat eigentlich
geführt sich nur über wasser halten weiß
er magdeburg auch nicht die guten jobs
gehabt aber es hat mir gezeigt ja was
passiert da macht man etwas anderes und
das ist was für mich ja auch dieses ost
seinen ausmacht die gewissheit nichts
hat es beständig man muss sich auch
alles erarbeiten man kann aber auch
immer alles wieder neu anfangen und
wandel ist ständig
es gibt nichts was für mein name ist
eine kugel
ich bin sozialwissenschaftler an der
humboldt universität zu berlin
ich bin forscher ist und westdeutsche
identität für die die eltern generation
der jungen aus deutschen ist die
abwertung erfahrung auch erstmal ganz
reale abwertung gewesen die waren so um
die 30
zwischen 20.30 und hatten sozusagen ihre
karriere vor sich und hat tatsächlich
eine abwertung in ihrem lebenslauf wagen
um eine ökonomische soziale strukturelle
abwertung haben die chefs aus dem westen
bekommen die ihnen dann erklärt ein
bisschen laufen soll und es sind
familien geschichten die ihnen ganz
viele ostdeutsche familien immer wieder
und immer wieder und immer wieder
geteilt werden ja diese erfahrungen der
90er jahre
warum kann der ostsee nicht vom affen
abstammen
ein affe hätte es 40 jahre lang nicht
ohne bananen ausgehalten sehr
schablonenhaft gerade auch nach dem fall
der mauer heißt es immer so ist der
osten das ist der osten im letzten jahr
wirken ja sachsen thüringen und
brandenburg und medial hieß es der osten
wählt würden wir dann jemand sagen der
westen wählt würden wir natürlich nie
sagen wir würden immer sagen was sind
die spezifika von bayern beispielsweise
vielleicht muss man ab und zu mir
nachfragen mehr hinschauen dass man mehr
zusammen findet und dass man vielleicht
wieder schüleraustausch in den westen
hat in den osten braucht dass man sich
erst mal gegenseitig annähert bevor man
die welt entdecken möchte vielleicht
sollte man sich in der schule auch mehr
mit den lebensverhältnissen beschäftigen
ja straße war böse aber das ist auch
eine anders der ddr gab dass das wird
gar nicht so damit setzt man sich nicht
auseinander und geschichtsunterricht
kann auch ich sag mal unterschiedlich
gestaltet werden mit meerblick winken
auf ein thema es fehlt das wissen über
die anderen ist scheint kein dran zu
geben dass näher mit dem osten zu
beschäftigen
ich glaube das ist mittlerweile auch
recht deutlich geworden ist dass es
einfach die ideen aus die nicht gibt und
dass wir sozusagen wissen ist dass die
ostdeutsche also die aus deutsche teil
gesellschaft vielfältig ist das sie
diverses in dem ost west diskurs ist es
sehr offensichtlich dass die norm oder
das was als norm angenommen wird ist der
westdeutsche bürgerliche weiße mann der
mehr oder weniger davon ausgeht dass so
wie er seine biografie gelaufen ist das
normal als normal gilt
ich bin zurück nach wittenberg weil es
immer noch meine heimat ist und die
ausbildung gemacht und bin jetzt
zahntechnikerin in leipzig die arbeit
die ich jetzt mache die würde in
westdeutschland mit einem tausender mehr
anfangen und das frustriert ungemein
wenn man weiß man macht die gleiche
arbeit und man macht überstunden man
schuftet und man bekommt weniger geld
das ist eine zweiklassengesellschaft
einfluss auf die chancen ob ich in
ostdeutschland oder in westdeutschland
geboren wurde
es macht einen unterschied in echten
sozusagen ökonomischen sozialstruktur
allen unterschied wie meine chancen sind
an bestimmte positionen zu kommen oder
ein bestimmtes gerät zu haben
eine westdeutsche kommen den ton an
sagte einmal zu mir
der fuchs ist schlau und stellt sich
dumm de rossi macht das anders
witzig gemeint so kam es bei mir jetzt
nicht unbedingt an
im osten hat der schule zu bleiben hatte
halt wirklich wenig perspektive dass es
gab wenig arbeitsplätze unsere eltern
haben uns ja alle weg geschätzt wir
sollten anderen im westen gehen sollten
da studieren weil es natürlich auch
wesentlich mehr prestige brachte an
einer west ohne zu sein als in
ostdeutschland
der goldene westen
wenn ich an weihnachten zurückfahren
nachbarn unterhalte man schon ein bild
das die flacher stellen aus gold sein
müssen wir menschen dass man vieles war
auch anders er hat in münchen zum ersten
mal rentnerin mit pelzmantel sich das
kannte ich jetzt nicht was mag da muss
es haben wir müssen über geld reden denn
abend tot in diesem land der westen und
nicht der osten also wer in meinem
umfeld zieht und eine eigentumswohnung
und die eigentumswohnung ist nicht
selbstständig und allein finanziert
worden wer tut er's denn das tun eben
menschen aus westdeutschland wir wissen
dass ostdeutsche auf meiner generation
wendekinder uns fehlt es an
sozialkapital also an netzwerken ein
glaubenssatz in meiner familie war
du kannst alles werden wir unterstützen
dich auf deinem weg egal was du machen
möchtest wir sind an deiner seite
wir können hier nur nicht sagen wie und
wir haben keine verbindungen und wir
können dir bei diesem weg und den
genauen schritten leider nichts sagen es
gibt keine handlungsanweisung in unserer
familie und das ist definitiv etwas das
immer durch schienen- und was mich auch
geprägt hat
im westen waren die renommierteren uni
ist glaube ich bin 2006
ein paar wochen später wurden die zur
elite uni erklärt jan später ist dass
man hat dann in münchen studiert das ist
wie ein gesamtdeutscher lebenslauf wenn
ich mich bewerbe hab ich war ich da und
mir kommt vor dass viele leute das auch
viel besser begreifen können weil sie
wissen was münchen ist und sie wissen
was das für eine uni ist hätte ich jetzt
erklärt ich hätte an der hochschule
anhalt in dessau studieren was anhalt
was ist denn da muss man noch so viel
erklären dass man da auch eine gute
ausbildung bekommen
ostdeutsche haben kaum macht oder sehnen
die macht nicht in aktion in ihrem
alltag seit 16 jahren haben wir eine
ostdeutsche frau als bundeskanzlerin an
der spitze des staates aber eine person
macht eben nicht den unterschied wir
haben 17 millionen ostdeutsche und sie
sind aber eben bei weitem nicht
repräsentiert
elite rekrutiert sich selbst und wenn
die elite von westdeutschen männern
allen staaten vor allen dingen besetzt
ist und die sich selbst rekrutieren ist
es nicht überraschend dass die sozialen
die diebin gleichen wieder rekrutiert
werden
da können jetzt erstmal gar nichts tun
und können jetzt auch sozusagen erstmal
gar nichts dafür dass sie da nicht sind
wenn man so eine idee davon hat das
soziale ungleichheit
das ist eine aufgabe des staates ist
wäre da sozusagen gegen zu wirken denn
dann muss da auch was getan werden dann
ist das auch eine politische aufgabe ist
da wo politik was tun kann darauf was zu
tun
die infrastruktur in bundesländern wie
sachsen anhalt ist furchtbar
also wenn man als er zu mir zur schule
möchte dann fahren manche ganz viele
stunden an durchs land wir hatten bis
vor ein paar jahren in halle eine
meisterschule für zahntechnik die worte
arbeit dicht gemacht und wenn das so
weitergeht dass auch die meisten schulen
schließen dann kann es natürlich
passieren dass die leute auch eine
andere bundesländer abwandern einfach
nur weil sie den beruf erlernen wollen
und dann stirbt das handwerk vor ort
aber aus und das ist natürlich dann so
eine spirale es wird immer weniger und
immer weniger junge leute bleiben und
dann haben
eine starke abwanderung region würden
aussterben sind am aussterben alte leute
um das problem dass sie nicht in die
stadt kommen zum einkaufen das ist auf
dem land eine sehr schlechte versorgung
gibt und der bus fleisch nur zweimal am
tag fährt
überall dort wo lebensqualität verloren
gegangen so infrastruktur situation hat
post hat beschlossen polizei ist
ausgedünnt worden
das war für die rechten in leerraum dem
sie versuchen zu füllen
man hatte ja jahrzehntelang eigentlich
die möglichkeit rechte strukturen
aufzubauen
es gibt überhaupt keine
zentralhaltestelle wo nachts einmal die
stunde alle bahnen zusammenkommen das
problem war aber das macht sich also die
ganze stadt an dieser einstelle traf und
hatte lange haare als jugendlicher ich
hatte aufnäher auf dem rucksack auch
gegen nazis ticker und man steht einfach
da wartet auf den bus und kriegt eine
ins gesicht geschlagen dass also ich hab
nicht mehr alle original täter dadurch
mit dieser richten gewalt auf der straße
hat man aber einfach gelebt das war halt
normal
das war alltag schlimm war es sich
geführt die man dafür interessiert
die fdp ist öffentlich sehr präsent sie
ständig auf dem marktplatz sie macht
ständig irgendwelche bürgertreffs und
dass er weg natürlich auch bei vielen
den eindruck dass ich nur die afg
kümmern würde
auch wenn der glaube ist andere parteien
machen dass weniger effektiv weniger oft
und das ist das problem
natürlich hätte man dafür sorgen müssen
dass rechtspopulisten gar nicht den
platz haben können den sie jetzt haben
und dass menschen der meinung sind sie
müssten jetzt eine rechtsextreme partei
als neue ost partei wählen und
letztendlich bin ich jetzt bei einer
satire partei gelandet und versuche
wahlkampf zu machen und leute auch dafür
zu begeistern die demokratie selbst
mitzugestalten
[Musik]
also meiner erinnerung an die deutsche
einheit sind deutschland fahren und
helmut kohl aber die deutsche einheit an
sich verbinde ich eigentlich erst in den
letzten jahren natürlich mit der frage
von jubiläen und warum kriegen
ostdeutsche immer nur dann temporäre
sichtbarkeit wir leben 30 jahre nach der
wende die ddr gab es nur 40 jahre und
noch immer fehlt uns noch ein
gesamtdeutscher blick jedes jahr spricht
man einmal darüber dass es nicht gleich
ist und erörtert jedes jahr die gleichen
gründe und was man alles besser machen
kann aber es passiert nichts
das ist ein skandal
[Musik]